قصف اسرائيليه يستهدف من حيث مطار الضبع
العسكري ويخلف 5 اصابات في رفح حفص
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا تدعو المجتمع الدولي للعمل ضد
رئاسه روسيا لمجلس الامن وموسكو تؤكد
زياره الافروف لنيويورك
وبعد كورونا فيروس ماربورج يثير الرعب في
العالم ودول العربيه تحذر مواطنيها من
السفر الى تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا نشره الاهم الانباب من العربيه افاد
مراسل العربيه بان قصف اسرائيلي على سوريا
استهدف محيط مطار الطبع العسكري في ريف
حمص وقال مصدر عسكري سوري لوسائل اعلام
رسميه ان ضربات خلفت بعض الاضرار الماديه
كما نتج عنها اصابه خمسه عسكريين وفي حين
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعاقب على الهجوم
كانت وكاله الانباء السوريه قد اكدت بان
الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لهجوم اسرائيلي فوق
محافظه حمص
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ان ثلاثه
اشخاص اصيبوا بجروح احدهم حالته خطيره في
عمليه دهس بالقرب من قريه بيت امر شمال
مدينه الخليل في الضفه الغربيه قال
المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ادرعي ان
منفذ عمليه الدهس تم تحيده في حين اشارت
صحيفته جراز الى اطلاق النار على المهاجم
في موقع الهجوم دون ابداء مزيد من
التفاصيل
قبل ذلك انطلقت تظاهرات شارك فيها الالاف
في شوارع تل ابيب الرئيسيه وبحسب وسائل
اعلام الاسرائيليه ضمت تظاهرات انصارا
اليمين المعارضين لتعليق رئيس الوزراء
الاصلاحات القضائيه كما انضمت محتجين
معارضين للاصلاحات بشكل عام
منذ بدايه العام والتظاهرات في اسرائيل لم
تهدا ضد خطه نتنياهو والتي يسميها اصلاحا
قضائيا ورغم ان نتنياهو قرر ارجاء التصويت
على خطته وفتح الباب للحوار الا ان
الكثيرين لم يصدقونه وظلوا في الشارع
يتظاهرون للمطالبه بالغاء الخطه برمتها
وليس فقط ارجاء التصويت عليها
هولدت كانسل الايقاف لا يعني الغاء القرار
نحن نريد منه ان يلغي قراره وان يجلس معنا
ونضع خطه لكي نتمكن من العيش سويا سواء
كنا عرب او يهود او بدو او مسلمين او
اوروبيين جميعا يجب ان نعيش في سلام
وديمقراطيه وهو يحاول ان يدمرنا لذلك نحن
هنا وسننجح
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل ان مناصرين لنتنياهو بعض الاحزاب
اليمنيه المتطرفه باتهم ايضا ينزلون الى
الشارع لمطالبه نتنياهو بالثبات على قراره
وعدم التراجع ما يعني ان صدام الشعبي
الداخلي في اسرائيل بات امرا واردا اكثر
من اي وقت مضى من مدينه تل ابيب عبد
الحفيظ جعوان العربيه
في السودان اتفق الاجتماع الذي عقد في
القصر الرئاسي على حل نقاط الخلاف
المتمثله في وضع توقيتات لعمليه دمج الدعم
السريع داخل الجيش بهدف التوقيع على
الاتفاق النهائي في السادس من ابريل
جديد لكن يبدو انه قابل للتاجيل فهو مشروط
بحل خلاف يبدو معقدا بعض الشيء
الاتفاق السياسي الذي كان من المقرر
توقيعه اليوم السبت اجيل الى السادس من
ابريل على ان تحل نقاط الخلاف خلال الايام
المقبله الاجتماع الذي انعقد في القصر
الرئاسي وضم رئيس مجلس السياده ونائبه
والقوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
للخروج بهذا الحل لم يستغرق وقتا لكنه ترك
قضايا معقده تتطلب الكثير من الزمن
الاطراف الحاضره بالاجبار العسكريه
ان تكثف من جهدها لحل هذه القضايا الفنيه
العالقه خلال الفتره من الليله وحتى يوم
السادس من ابريل
الورشه المعنيه بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري
اختتمت قبل ايام دون توصيات او نقاط اتفاق
بل انها وسعت الخلافه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الذين تحدثا بشفافيه غير عن كل ما
يراه احدهما في الاخر اما الموضوع الذي
ادى الى تاجيل الاتفاق والمتمثل بوضع
جداول زمنيه لدمج قوات الدعم السريع داخل
الجيش فالامر ما زال معقدا بتقدير الخمسه
ايام غير كافيه لانه البون شاسع جدا ما
بين مطالب الدعم السريع ومطالب القوات
المسلحه والامر قد ياخذ زمن اطول انا
اعتقد اسبوعين قد تكون كافيه
قد نشهد في السادس من ابريل احتفال
السياسيا يضم الاطراف المختلفه بعد حل
قضاياهم العالقه وقد نشهد تكرارا لمشهد
اليوم بتاجيل جديد في موعد الاتفاق
النهائي ليعقوب العربيه الخرطوم
وفي تصريحاته العربيه كاد رئيس المجلس
الاعلى لنظرات البيج محمد الامين ترك رفضت
توقيع على الاتفاق الايطالي معتبرا انه لا
يمثل قضايا شرق السودان ومشيرا الى ان
القائمين على الاتفاق هي ذاتها النخب
السياسيه التي استعمرت شرق السودان زمنا
طويلا بحسب وصفه هذا الاتفاق لن يشمل
قضايانا ولن نعرف فيه ما كتب ولو حرف واحد
فلذلك يعني لا يمكن ان نقبل باتفاق نحن لم
نكن فيه طرف وايضا نحن ناكد موقفنا مع
شركائنا في
الكتله الديمقراطيه للتغيير
وايضا مع كل المعارضين لهذا الاتفاق
في العراق قالت وسائل الاعلام كرديه بان
عمليه استئناف تصدير النفط من اقليم
كردستان العراق ستتم خلال 48 ساعه المقبل
واشارت الى تشكيل غرفه مشتركه من بغداد
واربيل التي ستشرف على بيع النفط في اقليم
كردستان بطريقه منظمه وعمليه
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
روسيا رئاسه الدوريه لمجلس الامن التابعه
للامم المتحده بالامر السخيف واضاف ان
تولي روسيا هذه المهمه في مجلس الامن يكشف
عن افلاس تام للمؤسسه الدوليه وفق تعبيره
وكان وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتري
كوليبا قال ان رئاسه روسيا لمجلس الامن
الدولي صفعه في وجه المجتمع الدولي ودعا
في تغريده عبر تويتر الاعضاء الحاليين
للمجلس الى التصدي لاي محاوله روسيه
لازاله استخدام رئاسه المجلس بدورها ردت
موسكو على هذه الانتقادات واكدت بين وزير
خارجيتها
الى الامم المتحده هذا الشهر خلفا
ميدانيا اعلنت اوكرانيا عن استخدامها
لذخائر الهجوم المباشر عاليه الدقه وطالبت
واشنطن بالمزيد منها الاعلان الاوكراني
يتزامن مع اعلان الروسي اخر بزياده انتاج
السلاح بانواعه كافه
400 يوم على الحرب في اوكرانيا في كل يوم
منها يزداد التصعيد على جميع الصعود من
تصريحات سياسيه وتهديدات الا ان اشدها
وضوحا هي ازدياد تدفق الاسلحه على
الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني اخر الاسلحه
الذكيه التي اعلنت اوكرانيا عن استخدامها
هي ذخائر الهجوم المباشر المشترك والتي
تعرف بجدم والتي تحول القنابل العاديه الى
تلك الموجهه لاصابه الاهداف بدقه اكبر
نجحت طائرتنا بواسطتها في ضرب اهداف مهمه
انها قنابل اقل تاثيرا قليلا ولكنها دقيقه
للغايه
ضمن حزمه المساعدات الامريكيه لكييف
لتطالب بالمزيد منها خاصه بعد تصريحات
مسؤولين امريكيين عن امكانيه الاعلان عن
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده بقيمه مليارين
و600 مليون دولار تتضمن ذخائر جويه دقيقه
حرب التسليح على الجانب الروسي تستمر ايضا
لتعلن موسكو عن زياده انتاج جميع انواع
الاسلحه العاديه وعاليه الدقه وفق وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه
تم تحديد حجم امدادات الذخيره الاكثر
احتياجا ويجري اتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لزيادتها وبسبب التوسع في القدرات
الانتاجيه وزياده انتاجيه العمل ازداد
انتاج المصانع الدفاعيه للاسلحه التقليديه
والاسلحه عاليه الدقه لدعم القوه باعداد
مضاعفه
مؤشرات حرب عالميه ثالثه تؤكدها كييف
بمطالبها برفع ضخ السلاح وموسكو بعقيدتها
الجديده والتي في كل بند منها تؤكد على
نيتها ليس في الانتصار فحسب بل في قلب
الادوار وكسر شوكه واشنطن اذا عمر العربيه
طلبت كيف هولندا 100 ودرهم متعدده المهام
من طراز روس وماك تصنعها بترخيصا من
فنلندا
حامله الجنود المدرعه رسومات
مدرعه متعدده المهام
ذات ثماني عجلات
تنتجها بولندا بترخيص من فنلندا
وتوصف بالاكثر حمايه
ومسلحه بمدفع عيار 30 ملم
المدرع محصنه ضد الالغام من الدرجه الاولى
[موسيقى]
وقادره على حمل عشره جنود
وهي مجهزه بصواريخ سبايك الموجهه المضاده
للدبابات
وهي مجهزه ايضا بمحرك بقوه
603 احصنه
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال الامريكيه
لالتهابات الموجهه ضد براسلها ايفان
الذي اعتقلته الاسبوع الماضي للاشتباه في
قيامه بالتجسس وطلب تصلات الروسيه
بالافراج الفوريه عنه وفي تغريده قالت
الصحيفه انها تعتبر الالتهابات اهانه
قاسيه لحريه الصحافه مشدده على انه لا
ينبغي احتجاز اي مراسل لمجرد قيامه بعمله
مع اتساع رقعه التحذيرات في الدول العربيه
من السفر دعت الامارات والكويت والبحرين
والسعوديه المواطنين لتجنب السفر الى
تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه بعد رصد تفشي
لفيروس ماربورك وضعت وزاره الخارجات
الاماراتيه في بيان لها مواطنيها
المتواجدين هناك بضروره اخذ الحيطه والحذر
واتباع تعليمات السلامه الصادره عن
السلطات المختصه بدورها طلبه الخارجيه
الكويتيه من مواطنيها تجنب السفر الى
تنزانيا وغينيا الاستوائيه مشيره الى ان
ذلك جاء استنادا على توصيات المركز
الخليجي للوقايه من الامراض ومكافحتها
وتوصيه وزاره الصحه
بدورها حضرت الخارجيه البحرينيه مواطنيها
من مخاطر السفر الى الدولتين واكده على
ضروره اتباع النصائح والارشادات عند
الحاجه اليها
[موسيقى]
وبعد معاناه طويله عاشها العالم مع فيروس
كورونا على مدى الاعوام الثلاثه الماضيه
زادت المخاوف من تكرار ذات سيناريو وهذه
المره مع فيروس ماركا
نادر مميت ومرتبط بفيروس ايبولا هذا كل ما
نعرفه عن فيروس تم اكتشافه في دولتين
واقعتين على جانبي القاره السمراء ويسمى
لكن الامر ليس مستغربا فمنذ ثلاث سنوات اي
عند انتشار فيروس كورونا عجز الاطباء عن
معرفه تفاصيل كامله او دقيقه حول الفيروس
لتاتي بعدها الدراسات التي فسرت طريقه
انتشاره وعوارضه
عموما تصيب فيروسات مثل كورونا ايبولا
ومار بورد الحيوانات عاده وتنتشر الى
الاشخاص في بعض الاحيان لكن عدم معرفه
المصدر الحيواني الاصلي للعدوى يبقي مسارا
انتقال عدوى الفيروس للشخص غير واضح خبراء
الصحه رجحوا ان تكون اصابه الشخص الاول
بالعدوى نجمت عن التعامل مع حيوان مصاب
بالعدوى او اكله لتكون بدايه للطفره
الاولى منه لتنتقل العدوى بعدها من شخص
الى اخر اما باتصال مباشر بالجلد او
بسوائل كاللعاب او الدم وكما بدايات
كورونا مؤشرات عده اشارت الى انه لا يمكن
للاشخاص نقل العدوى قبل ظهور الاعراض
عليهم اما عن مرحله ما بعد الاصابه وبحسب
خبراء يقوم جهاز المناعه بالقضاء نهائيا
على الفيروس فيما يبقى لبعض الوقت في
مناطق من الجسم محميه من الهجمات من قبل
جهاز المناعه
اياد حمود العربيه
اعراضه شبيهه بالانفلونزا لكنها قاتله بعد
ايام فقط من الاصابه به فيروس ماربورج
المرعب يظهر مجددا في افريقيا ويثير مخاوف
العالم فما قصته ينتمي الى عائله فيروس
ايبولا الفتاك وتتراوح معدلات الوفيات به
بين المصابين بين 24 الى 88 في المئه بحسب
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر فتره الحضانه
للاصابه بفيروس بين ثلاثه الى تسعه ايام
وتبدا اعراضه بالاصابه بصداع حاد ووعكه
شديده والام عضليه وفي الحالات المميته
تحدث الوفاء في اليوم الثامن او التاسع
خبراء الصحه يوضحون ان الوقايه بشكل عام
من الحمى النزفيه المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
باربورك او ايبولا قد تكون امرا صعبا ويجب
استخدام وسائل الحمايه مثل ارتداء قفازات
واقنعه وطرد الحشرات والقوارض لم يعتمد
حتى الان اي لقاح او دواء لعلاج فيروس
باربورك وتلقى المصابون الرعايه الداعبه
وعلاجات للمضاعفات والجفاف تعمل على تحسين
معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه وفق معظمه
الصحه
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
خوفا من محاكمه غير عادله فريق ترامب
القانوني يخطط لنقل محاكمته لولايه ثانيه
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت وكاله نقلا عن مصدر
مطلع في فريق ترامبا القانونيه ان الفريق
بصدد دراسه امكانيه نقل قضيته من محكمه
منهات الى محكمه اخرى وكان نفس المصدر ان
ارتفاع ترامب يخشى عدم حصول موكله على
محاكمه عادله في منهاته الا ان الفريق
القانوني ينتظر الحصول على لائحه الاتهام
المفصله قبل تقديم الطلب بنقل القضيه
[موسيقى]
شخصيات في قضيه ترامب سترومي دانييلز
اسمها الحقيقي ستيفاني ممثله افلام اباحيه
وتزعم انها كانت في علاقه غراميه مع ترامب
قبل ان يشتري صمتها مايكل كوهين محامي
السابق تحول الان الى شاهد الادعاء
الرئيسي ضد ترامب روبرت كوستيلو محامي
مقرب من كوهين وشهد ضده ونفاذ دفعه شامب
لمبلغ التسويه مادانينز كارن عارضه ازياء
تزعم ان علاقه جمعتها
150 الف دولار مقابل صنفها ديفيد بيكر
مدير دار للنشر اتهم ماكدوغان بتلقي اموال
المقابله قصتها مع تشومب دون وفائها
بالعقد
كشف ان ترامب حصل على تمهيد 37 جمهوريا من
الكونجرس في قضيتهم مضيفا ان هؤلاء
المؤيدين يشرفون على لجان القضاء والرقابه
هذا وافادت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بتلقي
حمله رئيس السابق دعما ماليا كبيرا بعد
اتهامه جنائيا وفقا للبيان الصادر عن حمله
ترامب الرئيسيه جمع الرئيس السابق اكثر من
اربعه ملايين دولار خلال الاربع والعشرين
ساعه الاولى منذ اعلان الاتهام
يبني جدارا في الكونجرس لتعزيز حملته
للرئاسيه المقبله ولمساعدته على نبش سجلات
خصومه السياسيين والقانونيين الرئيس
الامريكي السابق بدا يعمل بقاعده تقول ان
احسن وسيله للدفاع هي الهجوم 37 نائبا
برلمانيا جمهوريا في مجلس النواب بالاضافه
الى خمسه اعضاء جمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ
في صف ترامب فوافق موقع اكسيوس يتواصل
ترامب الذي يواجه اتهامات جنائيه في
نيويورك عبر الهاتف مع مؤيدين له مثل رئيس
السلطه القضائيه في مجلس النواب جيم
جوردان ورئيسه مؤتمر الحزب الجمهوري الى
ستيفانيك لمناقشه تحقيقات مع الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن والمدعي العام لمنطقه
مانهاتن ومن بين ابرز الجمهوريين الاخرين
في مجلس النواب الذين يؤيدون ترامب جيم
بانكس
بالاضافه الى روني جاكسون فضلا عن اعضاء
في مجلس الشيوخ هم لينت سيغرام
هي خطوه جديده من الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب عله ينجو من اتهامات اموال
الصمت كما فعل في قضايا سابقه بلال
البجديني العربيه
في ظل استمرار الاحتجاجات العارمه في
فرنسا تراجعت شعبيه الرئيس ايميل باكرون
رغم مخاطبه المواطنين عبر مقابله
تلفزيونيه كما تسود مخاوف وتساؤلات
صوره البلد بنظر المستثمرين
اندلعت نيران الاحتجاجات حاول ماكرون
وحكومته اطفائها بلغه الصمت والتجاهل غير
ان السنه اللهب هذه المره تغلبت على خطه
الاليزيا ليصبح الاحتجاج فعلا متصلا
بالزمن والمكان والهدف اسقاط قانون
المعاشات
الشارع الفرنسي غاضب جدا من الرئيس
فماكرون احرق الجسور مع الحلفاء والشركاء
المحتملين على طاوله التفاوض وحشد اغلبيه
الراي العام الفرنسي ضده
ورغم المقابله التلفزيونيه التي اجراها
وكسر من خلالها صمته شبه التام ازاء اصلاح
قانون المعاشات ودفاعه عن التشريع الجديد
باعتباره ضروره اقتصاديه الا ان السخطه
اصبح حاله مرشحه للاستمرار
فمهمه مواصله حكم فرنسا اضحت اصعب امام
ماكرون بدون اغلبيه داخل الجمعيه الوطنيه
اذ ان تسعه عشر من النواب الجمهوريين ايد
اقتراح حجب الثقه عنه
الاهم من هذا ان الرئيس الفرنسي فقد ثقه
الراي العام الفرنسي فمعدلات شعبيه ماكرون
تراجعت لمدون الثلاثين في المئه
المحتجون الغاضبون يتهمون رئيسهم بالغطرسه
في التعامل ويعتبرون ان ثمت حاجه لوضع
نهايه لهذا الامر ايمانويل ماكرون ربما
اصبح بطه عرجاء تقول وكاله بلومبرك
الامريكيه ملمحه بذلك الى انه قد يكون
عاجزا عن الاستمرار في ممارسه الحكم فيما
دعت صحيفه الى بدء جمهوريه سادسه تكون اقل
سلطويه فصوره فرنسا بصفتها مقصدا للاعمال
تضررت جراء الاحداث الجاريه ما ايقظ مخاوف
ماضيه حول بلد غير مستقر اقتصاديا وسياسيا
ايضا بلال البجدين العربيه
قالت وسالوا على من بريطانيه ان حركه
طالبان تحتجز ثلاثه بريطانيين في
افغانستان منذ يناير احدهم سائح عاد الى
افغانستان بعد نجله الجيش البريطاني من
الاراضي الافغانيه منذ عامين واخر هو مسعد
يدعى كيفن كورونال والاخير لم يذكر اسمه
لكنه يدير فندقا في كابول في حين كادت
الخارجيه البريطانيه انها تعمل على تامين
الاتصال القنصلي مع المحتجزين الثلاثه
اكد مراسل العربيه على فتح سطح التوسعه
الثالثه بالحرم البكي لصلاه التراويح
تزامنا مع الاعداد المليونيه خلال شهر
رمضان حيث قررت الجهات المعنيه اتخاذ هذه
الخطوه لتسهيل حركه المعتمرين والزوار
والمصلين في المسجد الحرام ما عوده
الاعداد الكبيره للمعتمرين والزوار في مكه
المكرمه
[موسيقى]
سقط طفل في ثمنه من عمره في الثامنه من
عمره في بئر ارتوازي في مدينه كوباني شمال
سوريا وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
البئر بعمق 120 مترا وتستمر الجهود من قبل
المنقذين وهم مواطنون عاديون في المنطقه
لاخراجه بالوسائل
اعلنت اداره الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه عن
تسجيل هزه ارضيه جديده بقوه 4.2 درجه على
مقياس ريختر ضربت ولايه كاستمامونو شماليه
البلاد في حين لم يبلغ عن اي اضرار جراء
الهزه التي حصلت لاول مره في هذه المنطقه
منذ زلزال السادس من فبراير
لقي ما لا يقل عن 21 شخصا على الاقل
مصرعهم بعد اجتياح عاصفه كبيره عده ولايات
غرب ووسط وجنوب الولايات المتحده
العاصفه تسببت في اضرار واسعه النطاق في
بعض المناطق ما استدعى اعلان حاله الطوارئ
ونشر العشرات من افراد الحرس الوطني